Today is a very exciting, day we're in the middle of another shoot right now and there was a knock at the
door and i cried, oh my god
i'm so excited right now, my macs here i am actually crying right now
Can't even, oh, my, god i've been waiting a really long time for this, okay i'm just
Gonna i'm just gonna push it in look can
You, argue able to focus on these years like this, is i'm not this good of an actress
This is real emotion, oh???
?
My, god i'm just, gonna push it i'm just gonna put you might as, well keep filming, because i'm so happy right now
oh, my, gosh i
I can't believe it's here early
Oh, gosh ah (Groaning)
This is so incredibly heavy. Are you ready nice to match the outfit.
This, is the moment that i've been waiting for this is not only just any imac this is the 18 core
128 gigs of ram
Beautiful beautiful beast, hold, on i'm gonna, flip it around
(Exclaims) my, gosh
Haters will say i'm over exaggerating but i'm not
This, thing looks so so good
Here this is bow this is a freaking beast, oh?
Oh boy this is honestly
This is this is a moment here that we're all having together we're sharing this this moment
We're sharing this moment as one?
Wow.
Owwwwww! (Kicks box with foot)
Oh god i kicked it hurt it's, okay, work through the pain, Justine nothing else matters except this right now.
Cannot wait to get this thing set up so it looks like it's gonna open up this, way
Even this is like a dark rake is usually it's like, a, white little?
Cloth, okay we've got our power cable
Let's just open it up, while we're here, we're here i'm here
It smells okay?
The dog is gonna love stealing that, okay so
don't mind me
just, just let, me.
I don't want to i
just, want on make sure i
get this
so happy
What i know?
Okay, oh there's more in here this is our?
keyboard
And mouse is there anything else before i ditch this i'm saving this, box i usually get rid of?
Boxes but this is getting saved, because it's beautiful there we go?
Down one would think it would be easy, oh?
we are so beautiful
wow
Wait to edit on this sweet sweet machine
Let's say, we got in here i already know?
What's in here early i act like i haven't watched every single person that has done an unboxing of this thing already he looks me
Real i've seen, them all, oh?
The matte black keyboard
Oh, and it's the full keyboard - i haven't had one of those in a really long time, and and here's our map like
Oh, you sweet thing
What i'm curious see is did they change up the design, oh, no they didn't you
Still charge it here at the bottom this is so glossy i forgot i got the trackpad too i'm so glad i added this on?
Now this smells good this smells like, cinnamon
That smells like, ihop
Well through the sound of course i forgot, some things
Black, lightning cable apple issued, and what is in here or you know? What's in here?
I'm just being silly a, little black cleansing cloth to cleanse, my sweet
imax, body and
Black, apple stickers my heart my heart it's beating at a very rapid rate
Well it's only 84 beats per minute i'm okay?
Okay, that's it this, is the mu imac pro i've been waiting a really long time for this
This is definitely overkill for an unboxing video, oh? (yes it is)
my
goodness
Not swollen so i think we're all right, oh let's take. This long, we might as, well let's just take
This, off oh get real thin say
Those let's take this up to oh, you're, gonna look so good, oh, yeah take it off
i've got that cleansing cloth, oh whoops
i
Wish adele, was here right now can you imagine if she was here
Cuz, i wanted to sing to me, oh?
Joe this is it this is the new. Imac pro it's what i've been, waiting for i'm so excited about it oh man
It looks so good, well thank you guys so much for watching, i will be doing a setup video here very shortly
Unfortunately i'll be traveling for the next week so hopefully i can, do that very very soon but in the meantime
I'll just be thinking about you
oh
I smell so nice smells like, a, fresh mac
Yeah i'll see you guys later